welcome in now host of the Reuben report
Dave Rubin Dave wow what a day here
affirmative action is now effectively
over I know you just listened to
President Biden's statement saying this
cannot be the last word but it's
interesting also to point out that this
was based on some lawsuits that white
and Asian students felt that they were
being discriminated against them with
all of this and the justices also clear
saying if someone feels that they are a
victim of racial discrimination they can
still Sue they can also use an essay to
talk about what the president was saying
adversity and how race has shaped their
lives your thoughts on this momentous
ruling
well first I would say today is an
absolutely fantastic day to be an
American and to believe in the
institutions that protect America that
protect individual rights protect the
Constitution and rule of law and protect
equality over Equity uh you know one of
the things with affirmative action that
I think has confused a lot of people is
there's this sort of general idea out
there oh we would like to help black
people let's say so you want more black
people to be in college now at first
glance that might sound right but what
they never really take into account are
the second order of things there are not
unlimited spots in all of these
universities there aren't unlimited
spots at Med schools or at corporations
or anywhere else so if you are going to
elevate someone based on the color of
their skin which is a very trivial
characteristic if you ask me then you
automatically are going to have to
punish somebody else so in the past
Harvard used to discriminate against
Jews now they discriminate against
Asians and white people and I don't
think any kid who's let's say 17 years
old and he you know comes from a South
Korean family and they worked hard and
maybe they had a bodega like where I
grew up where a lot of South Korean
families you know own things like that
or owned a 7-Eleven something like that
that they should be discriminated
against if they worked hard and their
family taught them the right values they
have every chance to be part of the
American dream like everyone else all
America can do or all any Fair Society
can do is is give equal opportunity you
have to work hard get yours and yes some
of us start from different places some
of us are born into a lot of money some
of us are born into nothing some people
are born with abusive parents or from
drug addicts or all of the Litany of
things that life is all about a society
can only offer the opportunity to enter
the game and do the best you can so we
have removed you know the irony really
is that the other side always says that
there's that America is systemically
racist well in some cases they were
right like this one and now we have
removed one of those hurdles of systemic
racism so it's a great day well Dave
John honey I'm going to jump in so
basically this ruling says that colleges
and universities can still look at a
person's racial background it just can't
be the only factor in determining
whether that person gets in uh and then
as James Rosen was talking about as
President Biden just said in in his uh
his comments you know he spoke about
adversity looking at the adverse
background the economic background of
students and he also mentioned as he was
walking out a reporter asked is this a
rogue Court he said no it's not a normal
Court well no he's right about that it's
the Supreme Court so it's not a normal
Court uh but what are what are some of
the the drawbacks to this rolling you
know with the administration do you
think this is going to where are we
going to see now the executive branch
getting involved in the Department of
Education and pushing more colleges and
universities to look at it adverse
backgrounds what do you think
well unfortunately probably yes I mean
the Democrats have made it very clear
that every time the Supreme Court makes
a decision they do not like they want to
either pack the court or change the
makeup of the court or undermine the
court or say that the court is doing
things that are unconstitutional I mean
look it was last week that we had the
reversal of Roe v Wade and Kamala Harris
put out a video that day saying that
women's constitutional rights were taken
away it's completely 100 180 percent uh
untrue 180 degrees untrue so so this is
what they've done with everything so
they will use this as an excuse to
undermine the court further as for the
distinction and I'm glad you made it
that there's a difference between
looking you know choosing the amount of
people we have a certain amount of slots
available to let incoming freshmen and
we're going to choose it by race you
could yes I think it's I think it's okay
and you can probably argue with the
other way but personally I think it's
okay when a college a young student
who's a you know a junior usually is
when you're applying to college if you
write an essay and you talk about some
of the challenges that you've had that
perhaps could be related to your
ethnicity or race maybe that offers a
sort of a piece in the tapestry of what
could get you to college but not your
skin color alone and again you do not
solve
past discrimination with current
discrimination and that is what we have
removed so this is this is all good but
yes the Democrats and the administration
I just remember I mean Joe Biden doesn't
know what he's saying he's just reading
whatever they put in front of him so
they could have put a completely
opposite statement and that would have
been fine too I did hear an end end of
quote snuck in there uh from the podium
there so again and of course he has the
big interview uh with Legacy Media at
four o'clock let's see if they ask him
about Hunter Biden's plea deal we'll say
remains to be not much diversity with
his choice
Dave Rubin a pleasure good to see you
thanks for joining us today to react to
this major scotus decision if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell